[Music]
more of my exclusive interview with
Roseanne Barr do you think there are
other people inside you with multiple
personalities that actually speak and
you don't even recognize it
no not anymore I I'm full traded you
fully I fully integrated and I was fully
integrated at Stanford University about
12 years ago was it was at a medicine
that transformed your life no it's
therapy therapy like 20 years of it
you look you've had a lot of controversy
I've done the work though I just have to
Pat myself on the back there I wanted to
get better and this all happened to me
when I was pregnant with my son he's 23
grinning graduating from college very
proud but when I was pregnant with him
first I got pregnant first they
implanted six eggs and four of them took
and I was like oh my god how's it
playing at Hollywood and I told Bruce
Willis oh my god I'm having I'm having
quadruplets right beat up for a headline
and I was so excited but then I started
to lose them you know and and they put
me in this thing where you I absorbed
him my body absorbed and there was only
one egg left there and it was kind of
hanging and didn't know whether to come
or go so they did me on this biofeedback
deal where I'd say I want you to stay
into this machine it was an it it work
yeah it worked but this deep spiritual
thing of that it started to heal all the
parts of me that were crazy and out of
control
I noticed it as I learned to focus and I
learned to meditate and that helped me a
lot what therapy very one medication and
medication and you said and you really
embraced and I drank well I've always
been very religious since I was a little
girl like did I say this that I grew up
in a apartment building fulled Pollock
uh survivors and every Friday they would
come over to my grandma's apartment my
my grandparents owned a an apartment
building they brought 50 or so survivors
from the camp
and that's where I grew up and every
Friday would they don't come you had
family that was in Auschwitz and they
had yeah they all had tattoos and they
would say terrible things to me when I
was only three and they would tell me
the things and I mean it wasn't too it
was too much from my mind to handle and
then they would make me watch the
Eichmann trial too and I was only three
they go she needs to know it was a
little girls like her that they did this
on TV yeah the Eichmann trial mm-hmm
yeah
and so that split me emotionally deeply
it was a horror to me and it still is a
horror to me a lot of evil in the world
yeah but there's so much love that's
what I was gonna tell your son but
you're going through all this trash oh
go ahead
you've been a good one I want you to
tell your story go outside now I was so
scared to go outside oh my god everyone
thinks like my race you know and I live
on an island where it's all brown people
oh my oh hell you know my daughter says
every day people come in and they're
like we we know who your mom is and all
these things like that no I would go out
on the street and people just rush up to
me to tell me they love me and they
don't think you know what happened was
balanced to the other people that do
worse things and say me really mean
things that aren't political but or just
mean and I'll tell you I it blew my mind
cuz I'm like man I got more I've never
felt this kind of love from people it
has been overwhelming it's just I just
thank them I told him you know if it
wasn't for my pants I probably wouldn't
even be walking around it was just
devastating to be misunderstood it's the
worst thing and I want to sing that song
oh lord please don't let me show you
miss I want to sing
now I have a band I've always wanted to
sing I saw you singing the national
anthem oh that wasn't good that was not
good
did you see my follow up though I bet
you didn't cuz you're in the news but I
did a follow up beat the whole time I
followed up and grabbed your crotch and
spit well that's what the stupid picture
told me to do and they all are deserted
like brats off a ship but I was trying
to get make him laugh he said that'd be
so funny I go Cal do it right so I did
it and it wasn't funny and I learned a
lesson never take comedy advice for a
book picture you really it's important
to you and I remember what I liked me I
don't want him to hate me I like them
you wanted people this is what you said
to me you said this is not me this is
what you said awkward you said it's not
me you said to me you said I want people
to know who I really am that's what you
said - I know so here is it you know
there's gonna be a lot of people
watching cuz you're here tonight tell
those people who you are well I'm a
creative genius and this is this is not
a good feeling for an artist to be
treated this way and it's not a good
feeling for a citizen either and here's
Who I am
I'm somebody who cares about civil
rights you ought to reject what you call
me you call me racist I don't accept it
I Know Who I am and I'm not a racist and
the people who voted for Trump they're
not racist either and Trump isn't a
races sorry but you know we just have a
different opinion we all want the same
thing no we want people in the inner
cities that are living in feces and I'm
talking about my son goes to school in
San Francisco I go up there I don't just
blab and run my mouth I live my beliefs
I want people to know that I live my
beliefs I try and of course I fail but I
try and I get back up and try again I
don't want to interrupt you every second
but the one
you speak in your own words but you yeah
listen PC is sickening it is it's not
American not sure it started shall I
live around brown people like for
example would you not say why not say
African American people or I live around
African American people too yeah I live
in a real neighborhood I live behind
gates with bodyguards I live in a real
neighborhood of working people I chose
to do that you know I was gonna ask you
about all these other cost controversies
but you know what I've made a lot of
mistakes I live my life out loud you
know I do it when things are going too
far right I'm gonna go a little left and
when things are going too far left want
to go a little right because I would
like balance in the middle
I like middle America I like the middle
way I like the middle class I like the
middle opinion that balances two
extremes
most people in America I think think
like that no it's funny because a lot of
people I don't think I think a lot of
people misunderstand what motivates me
and what motivates me in this 2016
presidential election for me was about
what we call the forgotten man and
that's you know a lot of people don't
know and I've some people who people who
watch the show regular you know I was a
paperboy at a dishwasher at 12 cook
busboy waiter bartender I painted houses
I hung wallpaper laid tile framed fellow
for roof three stories doing roofing
that was decades of my life and I never
thought I'd be in this position I'm very
thankful for it every day but those
people we had at the end of eight years
of Obama thirteen million more Americans
on food stamps and 8 million more on
poverty in the worst recovery since the
40s and a 51 year low homeownership rate
and he doubled the national debt and
accumulated more debt than every other
president before him combined so it's
not politics because Republicans are
weak they are pathetically feckless weak
and spineless well I don't know a lot of
them a lot of them are because they're
all there's only one party come on they
all golf together they're not like on
other sides are pocketing public people
not a lot
taking the money every side both side
ever place they're taking them on swamp
washington dc's a sewer there's no doubt
about it but that's our money that's the
people's money